bonsoir à régis alors les bureaux de
vote ils ont fermé à 18h et tout au long
de cette journée bien malin celui qui
pouvait dire qui du spd ou de l'acide et
où se détacherait mais on vient
d'entendre est les deux camps à
l'instant les sociaux démocrates qui se
positionne bien pour l'emporter même
s'il faut rester encore prudent dans
l'attenté des chiffres définitifs
oui tout à fait les deux camps sont
effectivement encore au coude à coude il
semble quand même que l'as vence du spd
soit environ d'un point et on sait aussi
qu'un certain nombre de votes par
correspondance ne sont pas n'ont pas
encore été comptabilisées il aurait
tendance probablement à accentuer
l'avancé à 2 olaf scholz donc on est
dans une dynamique véritable pour le spd
mais on l'a vu la cdd ou à et par son
leader armin n'achète s'est positionné
pour former le prochain gouvernement
va-t-on revenir à la grande alliance
qu'on avait souvent guélat merkel mais
ça avec l'inversion justement des
rapports entre le spd l'a cédée ou ce
qui lui fait pourrait évincer les nerfs
qui était un petit peu les ce qu'on
attendait dans ce dans ce scrutin et qui
finalement ont fait un score moins élevé
que celui qui était prévu on les a
estimés autour de 15 16 ils sont en
dessous de 15 donc il ya eu des
surprises mais ce qu'on peut noter c'est
qu'il s'agit véritablement d'une année
d'une allemagne quand même morceler les
tractations vont durer très longtemps on
sait qu'on a l'habitude de ces travaux
de ces longues tractations et donc du
coup anglais la merkel pourrait rester
au pouvoir pendant encore quelques mois
ça pourrait aussi conduire à une
paralysie au niveau de l'europe s'il est
apte si le chancelier n'est pas désignée
suffisamment rapidement donc on est dans
une part d'incertitude sur comment va ce
que se former cette coalition sera
t-elle une coalition dans laquelle il y
aura justement trois parties la cd ou et
le spd est ce qu'ils vont s'entendre ou
finalement est-ce que le spd va décider
peut-être de faire une alliance avec les
libéraux démocrates et les verts est ce
que cette année on ça lui donnera ce
plus de 50% tout ça ça avec les
tractations une mathématique une
arithmétique très complexe très propre
en allemagne et qui peut durer des
semaines alors un mot et fille sur les
électeurs 60 millions d'électeurs
étaient appelés aux urnes les électeurs
allemands indécis vous l'avez dit tout
au long de cette journée finalement
comme si ce n'était pas si facile de
tourner la page de ses années avec
angela merkel au pouvoir
on a senti le l'ombre gigantesque dans
gala merkel sur ce scrutin a pesé sur le
scrutin elle était partout on l'a vu m
voilà ce candidat olaf scharf reprendre
la fiole ce pardon reprendre le logo le
losange les mains dans gala merkel sur
la poitrine qui sont un peu sa marque de
fabrique et puis on se sentait vraiment
même chez la candidate des verts
n'allait n'aborde bob bareback pardon on
sentait vraiment qu'il y avait une
volonté de s'inscrire dans la trace dans
gala merkel parce que cet héritage il
est effectivement immense et il est
celui d'une âme d'une allemagne stable
les allemands non le principal est la
principale préoccupation des allemands
c'est de conserver de cette stabilité
alors on a parlé de renouveau on a vu
effectivement ce nouveau visage de cette
leader des verts mais ça n'a pas suffi
visage visiblement à faire cette percée
espérée à propos conduire une nouvelle
femme à la tête de l'allemagne donc ça
va être encore très incertain à la
manière des électeurs allemands
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de partis
qui sont à plus de 10% c'est
exceptionnel quand angela merkel il y à
16 ans avait pris le pouvoir et bien il
faut se rappeler que la cd ou et le spd
tous les deux faisait plus de 70% des
électeurs aujourd'hui on le voit même
s'il s'allie il peine à dépasser les 50%
merci à vous régis le sommier ans
l'entente du harnais à la chatte la
soirée promet d'être long on va vous
retrouver tout à l'heure mais c'est
également alexandre planasse qui vous
accompagne à la caméra